Let's say you've banded together with a group of friends to create a freelance
photography company. You've taken on the role of manager and your friends are
the photographers. Customers describe photography assignments to you. And you
label the assignments with priorities. Each day you have a team meeting, where
you give out the highest priority assignments to your friends. Each
photographer can do one assignment per day. And every so often, you like to
review all of the pictures in the company portfolio. What are some of the
methods that might be carried out by objects of those classes? This is a very
open ended question. What you come up with will depend on how you imagine this
situation. There are a lot of correct answers here. I haven't specified every
single step of the program. So everything's open to interpretation. What nouns
do you want to make classes out of? And what are the methods that might go with
those nouns? I won't give an automatic grade but will be collecting the answers
and analyzing them.